a slew of arrests were reportedly made  in Kim Kardashian's Paris robbery case  several French outlets are reporting  that between 15 and 16 people were  arrested after being tied to the October  incident you may recall Kim was held up  in her Paris apartment and robbed of  millions in jewels and cash according to  reports officials were able to track  down the suspects with the help of DNA  evidence found in Kim's apartment the  reality star and mother of two recently  returned to social media after taking a  break following the scary incident Kim  has yet to comment publicly on the  arrest but the family will finally  address the robbery on Keeping Up with  the Kardashians they're going to shoot  me in the back there's no way out it  quickly so upset the thing about it